في الايام الاولى من العدوان الاسرائيلي
على قطاع غزه في تويته انتشرت بشكل كبير
على موقع اكس او تويتر التويته دي كان
فيها صوره لطفل ميت وعلى ملابسه اثار دم و
وشه مش واضح ومكتوب فوق الصوره دي عباره
بالانجليزيه بتقول هذه اصعب صوره نشرناها
على الاطلاق نحن نرتجف بينما نكتب لكم هذه
العباره لقد ترددنا كثيرا قبل ان ننشر هذه
الصوره ولكننا بحاجه الى ان يعرف كل واحد
منكم ان هذا حدث التويته دي للوهله الاولى
بعضكم ممكن يتخيل مثلا ان اللي كاتبها
مراسل من اللي بيغطوا العدوان الاسرائيلي
على غزه واللي راح ضحيته لحد لحظه تصوير
الحلقه ما يقرب من 3500 طفل ولكن في
الحقيقه اللي ناشر التويته دي والصوره دي
هي وزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه من خلال
حساب تابع ليها على تويتر ومش بس كده دي
عاملها اعلان مدفوع بحيث توصل لاكبر عدد
من مستخدمي تويتر على اساس ده طفل
اسرائيلي قتل على ايد الفلسطينيين الاعلان
ده هو واحد من اعلانات كتير الاسرائيليين
بيعملوها حاليا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وبالاخص على تويتر طب ليه تويتر
بالذات ليه مش فيسبوك مثلا ببساطه لان
تويتر حاليا هو الميدان الرئيسي لاهم
معركه اعلاميه بياخدها الاحتلال في السنين
الاخيره المعركه اللي هتحدد بنسبه كبيره
قدرته على الاستمرار في العدوان على قطاع
غزه وتحقيق اهدافه من حرب المعلنه هناك
باختصار وعلى حد تعبير المتحدث باسم
البعثه الاسرائيليه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اللي قال بالنص قبل ايام الحرب ليست فقط
على الارض وانا في الحقيقه اتفق معاه جدا
الاسرائيليين مهما كانت قوتهم والدعم اللي
وراهم مستحيل يكسبوا حربهم المعلنه ضد
قطاع غزه بدون ما يفوزوا في معركه ثانيه
موازيه بيخدوها حاليا ضد الفلسطينيين وكل
اللي بيصروف واللي منهم بنسبه كبيره الناس
اللي بتشوفني دلوقتي وعلشان نفهم طبيعه
المعركه الموازيه اللي الاسرائيليين
بيخدوها حاليا جنب المعركه الميدانيه
فاحنا محتاجين نفهم الاول ازاي اسرائيل
بتستخدم الادوات والاساليب اللي احنا
كشعوب عربيه بنجه لها علشان تكسب المعركه
دي وثانيا بقى نعرف ايه هي نقاط ضعفهم
اللي ممكن كتير من اللي قاعدين بيتفرجوا
عليها دلوقتي يستغلوها بشكل واضح مش بس
للضغط على الاسرائيليين وانما كمان في
هزيمتهم وانا هنا مش ب على فكره في حلقه
النهارده باذن الله هشرح لكم ازاي وانتم
قاعدين في بيوتكم ممكن يكون لكم دور مهم
في صد العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه وانقاذ
ارواح اهالينا هناك وهضحك علاقه ايلون
ماسك وتويتر بالقصه دي حلقه مهمه يا ريت
شاركوها مع كل اللي تعرفوه وبفكرك ان
منصات ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عامله
قيود كبيره على انتشار المحتوى المضاد
للكيان المحتل فهمتكم معانا باللايك
والتفاعل مع الفيديو علشان يظهر للناس انا
اشرف ابراهيم ده المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا وفريق المخبر
الاقتصادي هنكون حابين نشكر جدا شركه
تلابت راعي حلقتنا النهارده شركه تلا فيت
اتاسس سنه 2017 وهي شركه فيتناميه اسسها
شاب مصري مكافح اسمه ضياء الدين امين
وبتصدر لاسواق مصر والسعوديه والاردن
وتركيا وغيرها تاجات مختلفه زي البن
والفلفل وجوز الهند والقرفه والكاجو
هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه تلفيت لو
في شركه او تاجر حابب يتعامل معاهم
ويستورد من خلالهم المنتجات دي يا ريت
تعملوا ده في اغسطس 2013 صحيفه هارتس
الاسرائيليه نشرت خبر مثير جدا للاهتمام
الخبر بيقول باختصار ان مكتب رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو قرر بالتعاون
مع الاتحاد الوطني للطلبه الاسرائيليين
انه يشكل وحدات سريه من الطلبه شغلتها
انها تقعد على فيسبوك وتويتر ويوتيوب
وغيرهم من شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي علشان
تدافع عن الحكومه الاسرائيليه ولكن يدفعوا
من غير ما يقولوا لحد انهم تبع الحكومه
المهم مكتب نتنياهو ك راصد للمشروع ده
ميزانيه قيمتها 3 مليون شيكل او ما يعادل
وقتها 810000 دولار امريكي وده علشان يوظف
من الجامعات الاسرائيليه السبعه حوالي 550
طالب بيعرفوا لغات اجنبيه واتحاد الطلبه
الاسرائيلي كان مهمته في القصه دي هو انه
يعمل مقابلات مع الاف الطلبه الاسرائيليين
علشان يختار الافضل من بينهم وبعدين في كل
حرم جامعي الاتحاد هيعمل مقر للمشروع ده
ويحط فيه اجهزه كمبيوتر للطلبه اللي هيتم
توظيفها في المجموعات السريه دي علشان
تشتغل من خلالها بعد ما الشباب دول يتم
اختيارهم بيتم تنظيمهم بشكل شبه عسكري في
كل جامعه بيتعين منسق رايس رئيسي المنسق
ده تحته ثلاث طلبه بيشتغلوا كمنسقين
فرعيين طالب مختص باللغات وطالب مختص
بالجرافيكس وطالب مختص بالبحث او ريسيرش
وتحت الثلاثه دول بيشتغل باقي الطلاب طبعا
كان مطلوب ان الشباب دول يكون عندهم حس
وطني ولكن ده ما يمنعش برض ان يكون في
حوافز علشان يبقى الحس الوطني اعلى
المنسقين الرئيسيين في الجامعات بياخدوا
منح دراسيه كامله والمنسقين الفرعيين
بياخدوا برض منح دراسيه ولكن اص اما باقي
الطلبه فبيا خدوا رواتب رمزيه السؤال بقى
دلوقتي الشباب دول بيعملوا ايه بالظبط على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بحسب تصريحات
مكتب رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه وقتها
فالوحده دي مهمتها دعم الدبلوماسيه العامه
او الشعبيه المؤيده للاسرائيليين من خلال
تطوير ونشر محتوى على شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي موجه بشكل اساسي للجماهير
الدوليه من الاخر كده الشباب دول مهمتهم
تحسين سين صوره الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والدفاع عنه ككيان قصاد العالم وده
بيعملوه من خلال نشر محتوى ايجابي عنه
والتفاعل بشكل معين مع الاخبار المتعلقه
بالاسرائيليين هنا واحد يسال سؤال منطقي
جدا هو من امتى الاسرائيليين بيهتموا
بالراي العام الدولي ايه اللي يخليهم
يهتموا اصلا طالما هم ضامنين دعم الحكومات
والسياسيين وصناع القرار في الدول الغربيه
وبالاخص في الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
السؤال ده هنلاقي الاسرائيليين جاوبوا على
دي في ورقه تم تقديمها في النسخه العاشره
من مؤتمر هرتسليا الاسرائيلي اللي تم عقده
سنه 2010 في الورقه دي هنلاقي الاسرائيليه
فيرا ميتشن شابير اللي كتبت الورقه بتقول
بالنص انه على الرغم من ان عمليه صنع
القرار فيما يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه
بيشمل دايره مغلقه من الناس وعاده بتكون
قراراتها متسقه مع اراء النخبه في كل
مجتمع زي السياسيين والمستشارين
والاكاديميين المشهورين الا ان الراي
العام مهم جدا الراي العام والتغطيه
الاعلاميه في المملكه المتحده بالاخص
بيحددوا حريه الحكومه فيما يتعلق باجن
السياسه الخارجيه المؤيده لاسرائيل يعني
باختصار شابير فاهمه كويس جدا ان الحكومات
الغربيه مش بتتحرك او بتاخد قراراتها في
الفراغ ما تقدرش تتجاهل الراي العام او
مزاج الناس بشكل مطلق وتايد الاسرائيلين
على طول الخط ده كلام مهم جدا جدا ضروري
كلنا ننتبه ليه بس عارفين ايه الاهم منه
عنوان الورقه نفسها وينن ذا باتل اوف ذا
ناريف الفوز في معركه السرديه عنوان خطير
لازم نقف قدامه ونحاول نفهمه لانه بيكشف
مدى فهم الاسرائيليين لطبيعه وجوانب
الصراع وخلونا نقف قدام كلمه ارتيف او
سرديه في سياق الحرب المقصود بالسرد هي
الطريقه اللي ناس بتنظر بيه للحرب داخل
عقولها يعني انت ليه دخلت الحرب وايه
اهدافك وهل هي اهداف مشروعه ولا لا كل حرب
لها سرد ديه ولها قصه في عقول الناس
بتتجاوز بكثير نقطه الارقام والاحصائيات
والمكاسب الميدانيه على الارض الامريكان
دمروا فيتنام في القرن اللي فات وكسبوا كل
المعارك اللي دخلوها مع الفيتناميين ولكن
برغم كده الكل تقريبا متفق ان الامريكان
خسروا الحرب في فيتنام وده ببساطه لان
سرديته عن الحرب خسرت والناس ما اشترتها
الناس ببساطه شايفه ان امريكا خسرت فتبقى
خسرت النظريه العسكريه حديثه بتقول ان
الحروب الدول ما بتكسبها في ساحات المعارك
بتكسبها في عقول الناس لو دخلت بلد
دغدغتها بس الناس شايفه انك ما كسبتش يبقى
انت ما كسبتش لا يكفي انك تكسب الحرب
العسكريه لازم تكسب كمان حرب السرديات او
الحرب الاعلاميه الاثنين ما ينفعش فصلهم
عن بعض ابدا بالعكس الثانيه امتداد للاولى
وكالعاده في الحروب بيكون في رديتيني لبعض
على سبيل المثال في المعركه الجاريه حاليا
بين الجيش الاسرائيلي والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه فيها رديتيني نفسوا على
عقول الناس في كل مكان في العالم السرديه
بتاعه الفلسطينيين ملخصها ببساطه هو ان
اللي حصل في 7 اكتوبر ده هو فعل من افعال
المقاومه المشروعه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ومحاوله لدفع العدوان واسترداد الارض
وتحرير القسر على الناحيه الثانيه السرديه
الاسرائيليه ملخصها هو انهم ضحايا لهجوم
ارهابي مالوش اي مبرر وان هم مظلومين
ومعتد عليهم من ناس ظالمه ما عندهمش رحمه
مين بقى اللي سرديته تكسب وتقنع الناس
خصوصا اللي ما يعتبرو ش طرف في الصراع دي
بقى هي المعركه الموازيه اللي
الاسرائيليين بيخدوها حاليا مش ضد
الفلسطينيين بس وانما كمان ضدنا كعرب
لاننا شئنا ام اباي احنا طرف في الصراع
باعتبارنا مناصرين لفلسطين ومناهضين
للاحتلال بالشكل ده العدوان الحالي على
غزه له شقين ما ينفصل صلوش عن بعض شق في
اشتباك عسكري وشق في اشتباك على مستوى
السرديات احنا والاسرائيليين دلوقتي بنتنا
فس على جذب نفس الجماهير تقريبا وهي
الجماهير الدوليه مواقف الجماهير المحليه
شبه محسومه احنا ورا الفلسطينيين بلا جدال
وعلى الناحيه الثانيه الجماهير
الاسرائيليه اللي بتسيطر عليها الرغبه في
الانتقام بعد اللي حصل في 7 اكتوبر
بنلاقيها لاول مره من سنين طويله تكون
متحمسه بالشكل ده للحرب وبما ان الجماهير
محليه مواقفها شبه محسومه فكده الطرفين
بتوع الصراع ما قدامهم غير الجماهير
الدوليه يتنافسوا عليها وكل طرف هيحاول
يقنع اكبر عدد ممكن من الجماهير دي بسرد
وفي نفس الوقت هيحاول يشكك في السرديه
المضاده او يثبت زيفها السؤال بقى دلوقتي
احنا كده عرفنا المعركه وعرفنا الجمهور
المستهدف ازاي ممكن نكسب او ازاي نقنع
الجمهور المستهدف بسرد هنا واننا على حق
وان الطرف الثاني ده سرد يته باطله
وبالتالي ياخد صفنا احنا مش هم انت علشان
تعمل ده محتاج اولا توصل للجمهور المستهدف
نفسه تتواصل معاه بشكل مباشر توصل له صوتك
الاجانب او الجماهير الدوليه اللي احنا
بنستهبل
لهم بطريقتين الطريقه الاولى طريقه غير
مباشره ودي عاده بتكون عن طريق وسائل
الاعلام التقليديه بتاعتهم سواء تلفزيون
او صحافه وهنا بقى بتظهر لنا مشكلتين
الاولى هي التحيز الشديد للسرد والروايه
اسرائيليه والتهميش والتحريف للروايه
الفلسطينيه والتحيز ضدها وده شيء اعتقد ان
ما فيش شخص عائل ومنصف ممكن ينكره المشكله
الثانيه بقى هي ان وسائل الاعلام
التقليديه وان واي ستريت شارع اتجاه واحد
ببساطه القارئ او المشاهد في الحاله دي
بيستقبل بس اللي بيتعرض له سواء في
الصحافه او في التلفزيون ما فيش مثلا مجال
انك وانت قاعد بتتفرج على التلفزيون توقف
المذيع اللي بيتكلم وتقول له انت كداب
وعديم الضمير والدليل اهو في السياق ده
بنلاقي ان سيطره وسائل الاعلام التقليديه
الاجنبيه على منافذ المعلومات وتاثير
الاسرائيليين على وسائل الاعلام ده حرمنا
بشكل كبير من ايصال حقيقه القضيه
الفلسطينيه للجماهير الغربيه المشكله دي
بدات حدتها تخف مع ظهور الانترنت ولكن
الانطلاقه الحقيقيه كانت مع ظهور وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي في العقد الاول من
القرن الحالي وبلاخص تويتر اللي بقى اسمه
اكس حاليا ولكن معذره انا هوشير ليه في
باقي الحلقه باسم تويتر لانه لا يزال
الاسم الاشهر للموقع المهم ظهرت وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي على الساحه باعتبارها
وسيله التواصل الثانيه مع الجماهير
الاجنبيه ولكنها وسيله اتصال مباشره جمهور
لجمهور تفاعل مباشر في اتجاهين ما فيش
وسيط في النص ممكن يحرف الحقائق او يتلاعب
بالسرد اشهر وسيلتين تواصل اجتماعي في
العالم كانوا وما زالوا هما فيسبوك اللي
اتاسس في 2000
وتويتر اللي ظهر في 2006 فيسبوك التابع
حاليا لشركه ميتا عنده النهارده ما يقرب
من 3 مليار مستخدم وتويتر عنده ما يقرب من
350 مليون مستخدم المنصتين لهم تواجد في
كل انحاء العالم السؤال بقى دلوقتي انهي
منصه في الاثنين ممكن من خلالها احنا او
الاسرائيليين نقدر نوصل صوتنا للعالم
ونبيع السرديه بتاعتنا تويتر ولا فيسبوك
والاجابه هي تويتر قولا واحده ما فيش
تنافس اصلا بال الاثنين في السياق ده
بالتحديد تويتر حرفيا هو الملك لما نيجي
نتكلم عن تكوين راي عام دولي او عالمي
فيسبوك اولا مش مناسب للمحتوى الاخباري او
السياسي وفي الفتره الاخيره بدا يبعد
تماما عن المساحه دي ثانيا فيسبوك زي ما
انتم عارفين بيحاصرنا المعيد لفلسطين بشكل
واضح وبيا ايد وصوله وده بيعمله من خلال
الخوز ميات ومن خلال الموظفين بتوعه تويتر
بقى على العكس يمكن اعتباره اكبر منصه
اخباريه تفاعليه في العالم من ناحيه
المنصه سمحت بظهور ما يعرف بالمواطن
الصحفي اللي ممكن من خلال تليفونه يشارك
مع الملايين من مستخدمي المنصه اي خبر او
حدث هو متواجد فيه سواء بالكتابه او
بالصوت والصوره ومن ناحيه ثانيه تويتر
بتطيح للجماهير العريضه من الناس العاديين
فرصه التفاعل مع فئه مش موجوده بكتافه على
فيسبوك وانا هنا بتكلم على رؤساء الدول
والحكومات والبرلمانيين والصحفيين
والاكاديميين والمؤسس س وغيرهم وغيرهم من
صناع القرار والراي الناس دي جزء كبير
منها موجود على تويتر مش موجود على فيسبوك
ولا اي وسيله تواصل اجتماعي ثانيه علشان
كده تويتر هو اكث وسيله تواصل اجتماعي
عندها القدره على التاثير في راي الناس
وتكوين راي عام تجاه اي قضيه دي حقيقه
اكتر ناس فاهمنها هم الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين كل الحروب الاعلاميه اللي
خدها الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين ضد بعض
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كانت حتها
الاساسيه هي تويتر ويمكن اول معركه واضحه
بين الجانبين على تويتر كانت هي المعركه
الاعلاميه اللي تزامنت مع العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه في 2012 الامر وصل
لدرجه ان الصحافه الاجنبيه اطلقت عليها
اسم فيرست تويتر وار او حرب تويتر الاولى
الطرفين دخلوا مع بعض حرب معلومات وهاشتاج
كانوا بيتنافسوا خلالها على عقول الناس في
كل انحاء العالم والاثنين اختاروا ان
الخناقه يكون ساحتها تويتر اللي كان موجود
عليه وقتها في 2012 ثلثين قاضه العالم
اللي كانوا عاملين حسابات هناك ده غير
باقي السياسيين والصحفيين وكل الناس
المهمه اللي بتتخرق او بتوجه الراي العام
ده حصل في 2012 وفي 2014 وفي 20121 وحصل
برده في 2023 من اللحظه الاولى لهجوم
كتائب القسام على الاسرائيليين في الاراضي
المحتله يوم 7 اكتوبر تويتر تحول لساحه
حرب من الاراء والاخبار والهاشتاج
والمعلومات اللي بعضها حقيقي وبعضها مزيف
الاخبار والتطورات والصور والفيديوهات
كانت بتنزل على تويتر بسرعه وبكثافة
اعتمدوا على تويتر من خلال متابعه الاخبار
ومراقبه الاراء والاراء المضاده اللي
الناس بتكتبها عن الحرب اللي ساعد في ان
ده يحصل هو ان ايلون ماسك صاحب تويتر على
عكس مارك زوكربيرج سايب الدنيا مفتوحه على
المنصه من غير قيود كبيره لا من خلال
الخوارزميات ولا الموديتور سايب الكل يقول
اللي هو عاوزه الى حد كبير واللي يقدر على
الثاني ربنا يعينه وانا في رايي ان ماسك
مبسوط بالوضع ده مبسوط ان تويتر بقى
الساحه الرئيسيه للمعركه الاعلاميه اللي
هي انعكاس للمعركه الميدانيه اللي شاغله
العالم كله دلوقتي اكث بكثير حتى من الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ولكن ده طبعا خلاه هو
والموقع بتاعه في مرمى نيران وسائل
الاعلام التقليديه اللي انتقدت عدم محاوله
تويتر للسيطره على المحتوى المهم اللي
يهمنا في السياق ده هو ان تويتر ساحه
مثاليه يقدر من خلالها كل مؤيد
للفلسطينيين وعداله قضيتهم انه يدعم
سرديته من خلال اشتباك في المعركه
الاعلاميه العنيفه الدايره حاليا على
المنصه وطبعا بما انك عاوز توصل صوتك
لاجانب فلازم تتكلم بلغتهم واللغه الاهم
في السياق ده هي اللغه الانجليزيه وهي
بالمناسبه اللغه اللي الاسرائيليين مركزين
عليها وده منطقي جدا لانها اللغه العالميه
الاولى اللي جزء كبير من شعوب العالم
بيفهمها ولكن طبعا معرفه اللغه مش كفايه
الاهم من اللغه هي الرساله نفسها دلوقت
انت كشخص اجنبي ما لكش علاقه بالصراع
وواقف تتفرج تصدق روايه او سرديه مين فيهم
السرديه الفلسطينيه ولا الاسرائيليه اللي
هيحكم النقطه دي ههم ثلاث عوامل المنطق
والادله والبراهين والتاريخ وركزوا معايا
كويس جدا في الجزء ده يا اخوانا خلونا
نبدا بالمنطق على سبيل المثال الادعاء
الاسرائيلي بان مجزره المستشفى المعمداني
اللي راح ضحيتها حوالي 471 مدني من اهالي
غزه يوم 17 اكتوبر هي نتيجه عمليه اطلاق
خاطئه لصاروخ من مقاومه مش من ضربه جويه
من الجيش الاسرائيلي ده ادعاء مخالف لابسط
قواعد المنطق مش لان مستحيل تحصل عمليه
اطلاق خاطئه وانما ببساطه لان الحجم
المهول للمجزر وضحاياها بيقول ان الشيء
اللي تم ضرب بهيه المستشفى قوته التدميريه
هائله جدا بشكل لا يتوافق ابدا مع القوه
التدميريه المعروفه لصواريخ المقاومه اللي
بنشوفها بتوصل الاراضي المحتله ومش بتعمل
عشر الضرر ده منطق بسيط شبه ده ممكن الناس
اللي فاهمه تشاركوا بلغه انجليزيه سليمه
مع الاجانب اللي ممكن ما يكونش عندهم
خلفيه عن الصراع واطرافه تخليهم قادرين
يحكموا على كذب او عدم معقوليه او عدم
منطقيه الاتهام ده ثاني نقطه ممكن تقنع حد
بالسرد بتاعتك هي الادله والبراهين
والاثباتات وده بيندر تحته حاجات زي الصور
والفيديوهات احنا مش محتاجين اكث من اننا
نشارك العالم المواد المرئيه اللي بتوضح
حجم الاجرام الاسرائيلي في حق دانين العزل
وبالاخص النساء والاطفال الصوره والفيديو
اقوى من اي كلمه وهنا احب اشارككم مقتطف
من مقال نشره الدبلوماسي الاسرائيلي ابا
ايبان في جيروسليم بوست في اغسطس
1982 بعد الدمار اللي اتسبب فيه القصف
الاسرائيلي للعاصمه اللبنانيه بيروت ايبان
كان بيشرح للاسرائيليين من وجهه نظره
كدبلوماسي حجم الخساره المعنويه اللي تسبب
فيها العدوان على لبنان للاسرائيليين في
السياق ده كتب ان الضحيه الرئيسيه خارج
ساحه المعركه تكمن في التحول اللي كان
بيشوفه في عيون اصدقاء اسرائيل بمجرد ما
اسمها يخطر على بالهم قال لهم خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره صورتنا في وعي اصدقائنا
كانت مرتبطه بصراخ الكاله والجرحى
والاطفال اللي بيقفوا طابور علشان يحصلوا
على المياه اللي الحصار الاسرائيلي حرمهم
منها الكلام ده كان في
1982 يعني قبل الانترنت والسوشيال ميديا
الصور اللي العالم ممكن يشوفها ان
النهارده عن جرايم الاحتلال في غزه ما
تقلش فظاعه عن اللي حصل في
1982 وفي نفس الوقت هي اكثر كثافه واسرع
للوصول اما العامل الثالث اللي بياثر على
قبول الناس لسرد الاطراف المتنازعه في
اطار الحروب فهو الزمن او التاريخ كل ما
طال امد الصراع كل ما الطرف اللي بيكدب
زادت احتماليه انكشاف كدبه مع الايام وكل
ما ده اثر بالسلب على قبول الناس لسرد في
كتاب ناريشن از ارجنت الصادر في 2017
وتحديدا في الفصل ال 12 اللي جه تحت عنوان
هاو تو وين ورز ذا رول ا ذا ور ناريف
الباحثين المحترمين بيوضح انه مع مرور
الوقت بتظهر الادله اللي بتاكد او بتنفي
السرديات المطروحه ولو انت كداب وبقى في
تراكم للادله المضاده للسرد بتاعتك فمع
الوقت السرديه دي مصدقيتها هتتاكل ولما
تفضل السرديه تتاكل ففي النهايه هتوصل
لمرحله هتبقى فيها عبق على الراوي او
الجهه اللي بتتب اناها هتبقى خلاص مش قادر
تدافع عنها لان الناس ما بقتش تثق فيك من
كتر كتبك ده على فكره اللي بيحصل مع
السرديه الاسرائيليه مؤخرا يعني على سبيل
المثال لما المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دانييل الجاري طلع ينفي انهم
قصفوا المستشفى المعمداني مراسل سي ان ان
سال سؤال بسيط جدا ليه ممكن العالم يصدق
كلامكم دلوقتي في حين انكم كذبتم قبل كده
فيما يخص قتل مراسله الجزيره الراحله
شيرين ابو عقله اللي قلته ساعتها ان
الفلسطينيين هم اللي قتلوها وهنا المتحدث
باسم جيش الاحتلال ما كانش قدامه غير انه
يبرر بان الجيش كان بيتسر في اصدار
الاستنتاجات والاحكام لكن في النهايه
تراكم الكذب ده ورا بعضه بيساهم في عدم
قبول الناس للسرد الاسرائيليه في حربهم
الحاليه ضد غزه ويمكن الناس اللي على
تويتر كان لهم دور كبير في كشف الاكاذيب
دي وتوعيه الناس ب انها اكاذيب على تويتر
ما حدش بيقول معلومه ويطلع يجري زي
التلفزيون مثلا لا اللي بيتقال بيتسجل
وبتلاقي بدل الواحد ال000 بيحفروا وراك
وبيجو بالحقيقه وبيثبت كذبك او تضليل لو
كنت كداب او مضلل والتغريد اللي بتتحذف
بتتجاب تاني وده يخلي تويتر افضل وسيله
ممكن الفلسطينيين وانصار قضيتهم يقدروا من
خلالها يبيعوا للعالم روايتهم للحرب ويدحض
الروايه الاسرائيليه الم ضده تويتر لا
يزال هو المنصه الاهم للتاثير في الراي
العام الغربي وبالاخص الامريكي عدد
مستخدمي فيسبوك في امريكا اي نعم اكث
بكثير من عدد مستخدمي تويتر ولكن برغم كده
تويتر هو الاكثر تاثيرا في صناعه الراي
الحقيقه دي الاسرائيليين مدركها اكتر من
اي حد بحسب تحقيق عم موقع بوليتيكو
الامريكي وزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
مؤخرا عملت في اقل من اسبوع 30 اعلان على
تويتر تم مشاهدته اكث من 4 مليون مره
الاعلانات اللي بدات تظهر اعتبارا من 12
اكتوبر كانت الوزاره الاسرائيليه بتستهدف
فيها الشباب اللي اعمارهم بتزيد عن 25 سنه
واللي عايشين في بروكسل وباريس وميونخ
ولاهاي في نفس الوقت الوزاره عملت 75
اعلان بمحتوى مشابه على اليوتيوب وتم
توجيههم للمشاهدين في الدول الغربيه زي
الولايات المتحده وفرنسا والمانيا
والمملكه المتحده طب ايه الهدف من
الاعلانات دي بغض النظر عن مصداقيه
محتواها الهدف منها ببساطه هو نفس الهدف
اللي المفروض يكون عند انصار القضيه
الفلسطينيه هو تحقيق ما يسمى
بالاستراتيجيات الاستراتيجي طب ايه هو
الاتصال الاستراتيجي ده مجلس الامن القومي
البريطاني بيعرف الاتصال الاستراتيجي بانه
الاستخدام المنهجي والمنسق لجميع وسائل
الاتصال لتحقيق اهداف الامن القومي من
خلال التاثير على مواقف وسلوكيات الافراد
الجماعات والدول طب هل وجع القلب والكلام
الكتير على تويتر بيفرق فعلا على الارض هل
الكلام على تويتر ومحاوله بناء راي عام
دولي مؤيد للفلسطينيين ممكن يكون له اي
لازمه قصاد الحقاق الماديه اللي بتقول ان
الاسرائيليين مثلا متفوقين عسكريا بشكل
كاسح ومعاهم على سبيل المثال للحصر اسلحه
فتاكه زي الاف 55 ده سؤال مشروع جدا من حق
اي حد يساله السؤال ده جاوبت عليه دراسه
اتنشرت في 2018 تحت عنوان ز سوشيال ميديا
انفلونس كونفلكت ايفيدنس فروم ذا 2012 جز
كونفليكت زي ما واضح من العنوان الدراسه
بتحاول تعرف مدى تاثير السوشيال ميديا على
الحرب الاسرائيليه اللي تم شنها على غزه
في 2012 وخلصت الدراسه دي باختصار هو ان
التحول في الدعم العام على السوشيال ميديا
لصالح الفلسطينيين ساهم في انخفاض حده
الصراع واستجابه الاسرائيليين لجهود وقف
اطلاق الن وبحسب الدراسه تاثير الدعم
العام على السوشيال ميديا كان اكبر من
تاثير اللاعبين الدوليين اللي انخرطوا في
مفاوضات الصراع وعلى راسهم مصر والولايات
المتحده والامم المتحده لحد هنا انا خلصت
كلامي واسف على الاطاله واتمنى انكم لو
استفدتوا من الحلقه تشاركوها او على الاقل
تشاركوا خلاصتها مع كل اللي ممكن يكون
مهتم بنصره اهلنا في غزه وكالعاده في
نهايه الحلقه عندي سؤال لحضراتكم يا ريت
تقولوا لي في التعليقات مين فيكم بيشارك
او ناوي شارك في حرب السرديات وفرض
السرديه الفلسطينيه امام العالم على موقع
تويتر هتلاقوا تحت الفيديو بيانات شركه
تلا فيت لو في شركه او تاجر حابب يتعامل
معاهم ويستورد من خلالهم المنتجات دي يا
ريت تعملوا ده في النهايه يا ريت لو
عجبتكم الحلقه يا ريت تعملوا لايك وشير
واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا
يمكن يستفيدوا
[موسيقى]
سلام
c